pretty changing topics though
M has have you ever fallen out of love
with let's say a hobby or something you
like because of a fan
base
because uh
anime anime just um yeah I wouldn't say
fallen out of love I would definitely
say like not be as vocal about it it's
probably the more correct way to say I
like I am I am getting to a breaking
point now MH because [__] one
piece fans man I I I don't know I don't
know when this is when this has started
to happen because to me like when I grew
up with One Piece One Piece was always
like the least popular like a sleeper
hit yeah the sleeper one out of like
bleach and Naro it was the most chill
out of the you know one piece fans were
like the most chill cuz everyone was
like yo Naruto yo bleach and one piece
fans are like yo we actually have a good
show you know just just ignore the art
style don't worry it's a really good
story just just get to it and
now at this current point in time I feel
like one piece fans are becoming the new
Dragon Ball fans oh and by the time this
episode is getting released I'm I'm I am
going to Hazard the guess that they have
fully transformed into the new Dragon
Ball fans you know why that happened
though because there's no Naruto and
bleach equivalent to keep them humble I
think I think whenever a show hits a
level of popularity it just happens
though yeah I mean there's it's it is a
level of popularity but I feel like they
are getting so [__] insufferable now
and I feel like a lot of this is around
the uh I mean this is probably the most
spoiled [__] thing in any popular
media because uh guys did you know that
you know gear five exists and uh it's
like the anime of that episode is like
coming out soon I would like to keep it
light on spoilers but I've seen [__]
massive exhibits of just like this new
Luffy form that they've just built and
I'm just like are people not even trying
anymore no like the exhibit the anime
exhibit thing in Japan they just don't
give a [__] because they're like cuz
they assume that everyone who's coming
to these exhibits just has caught up on
everything like I remember like I
remember first thing we ever talked
about in this podcast episode one I
remember I was talking about going to
the attack on Titan exhibit yeah right
that feels like a [__] decade ago but
like I remember I went there I'm not a
manga reader for a t on anime final
season hadn't even come out yet and I
was like oh there's an attack on Titan
exhibit let's go check it out I went I
got spoed to [__] because they literally
show every single like up to the latest
chapter in a frame and I'm just like
well great I just got [__] spoiled I
guess that's like me going to like van
go Museum be like [__] he made another
piece [__] that's like going to the van
go Museum be like [__] he's dead [__]
what he's not alive he cut his own ear
off what the [__] that's like me going
to the Vinland Saga exhibit and I'm like
what the the wiki spoiled everything the
wik the wiki spoiling what happens to
Thorin what's going on people being like
dude don't spoil
Oppenheimer I want to know what happens
guys did you know how bum explodes at
the end of Oppenheimer didn't didn't see
you know they made a sequel It's coming
out
too no but like yeah like my Twitter has
just been like unfuckin bearable
recently and a lot of that is just to do
with one piece fans spoil huh they got
too much good [__] yeah and and I'm I'm
sitting here being like I am a one piece
fan I love one piece it's one of my
favorite anime series of all time and
now I'm just like [__] I don't want to
like one piece I I don't I don't want to
be associated with it hasn't reached
levels of Rick and Morty there right it
I think it's getting there I think it's
getting there okay I I I literally saw a
tweet oh God this morning that was
literally like it it was like part of
like the paneling of like gear five and
there is like like this one this one
panel of uh something that Luffy does
and it's not like like a double page
spreader it's like something in the
background that Luffy does in this form
and uh they're like this is this is how
this power Works he isn't just doing X
he is literally like adjusting the the
molecules of his bodies to do this and
I'm like [__] one piece fan
when they see one panel and they call
odor like God you know what I mean like
Luffy taking a [__] [__] this is like
foreshadowing to like an arc that came
five ARS later I'm like oh my [__] D
I'm I'm waiting for the one piece I'm
waiting for the one piece scale power
scaling videos I guess I guess that's
what happens though when you have such a
long running show with so many rewarding
call backs or mentions of Prior
information is that you start to think
like he's got it all figured out yeah
well that's exactly what happened I'm
sure there's a good chunk of what Oda
writes where he just makes it the [__]
up on SP well that's exactly what
happened with like Naruto and bleach as
well like it went on for so long that
people just started to come up with
these like crazy fan theories that
neither of the you know creators ever
you know said was legit yeah and then
you just have people like [__] all
over the fan base because they're just
so hyperactive yeah and it's just like
it's just like a NeverEnding spiral and
now I feel one piece has gone to the
point again because there's no season at
least in the general consensus that is
on par or even above one piece that is
as long running as one piece so now
they're just in like an Unstoppable mode
they're like I also think those well
we're probably in a time where we see a
lot more negativity on social media in
general because it's rewarded more right
now like retreat culture so I think I
think it's probably a mixture of that
like one piece getting more hype but
then also social media websites
rewarding more dunking or controversial
takes it's it's all it's all just like I
guess like sensationalized you know
because like people are just like you
know by the time this is released
obviously the gear five episode is going
to be released UMO but uh half of my
time for the goddamn anime huh Ain
nobody got time for that anime bro
people calling this like uh like half my
timeline in terms of like one piece has
just been this is already the most
iconic transformation in anime of all
time Dragon Ball fans are dead don't
worry Dragon Ball's time is over gear
five Luffy is better than Super Saiyan
Goku and I'm just like what can you not
like something without dunking on
something else is that just not like a
is is that not like a possibility here
yeah but I mean Dragon Ball fans were
already doing that their own fan base
when like super saiyan blue came out
everyone was like yo this is the
Pinnacle Super Saiyan and Super Saiyan 3
eat [__] compared to this yeah I guess I
guess I thought one piece fans were
better I thought they were more
civilized than Dragon B thought we were
more civilized [__] just can't
like something like did you see like no
it's probably all the Dragon Ball fans
that were like I'm not going to watch
super anymore hey one piece and then
they just migrated over to the one piece
fandom it's the same fandom yeah cuz I
saw like uh Charlie got like a lot of at
least he on Twitter which I know it's
not real heat but you know it's it's
Twitter people being Twitter people but
I just it just like blows my mind where
he came out to be like I like I finally
like one piece you know Charlie most
critical fny likes one piece he just
doesn't like Luffy and then a lot of
people just absolutely hated him for
that and I'm like how could you not like
the main character I mean I think for
like half at least a good chunk of the
St Luffy is the worst character
yeah I mean Luffy is I mean he's just
like he's just like gone but like if
gone never grew up I I think uh I think
Luffy has his own charms as like a
protagonist but he's not my favorite
character in one piece but I can I can
understand as a one piece fan why
someone would not like you know would
not be the biggest fan of Luffy you know
I I see someone like Charlie being like
I'm a I'm finally likey one piece and I
see that I'm get I get excited I'm like
this is a [__] dub [__] yeah you
don't like Luffy okay understandable
have a nice day but
yo [__] there's plenty of other
characters you can fall in love with you
know and then I see like a lot of One
Piece fans being like [__] [__] Charlie
[__] he he does he's not a real one
piece he doesn't like one piece the
right way you know I I'm like like shut
the [__] up [__] shut the [__]
this is pissing me off so much yeah I
don't know it's uh it's one thing I've
noticed and one thing where you know
there's been a few instances where I've
liked something and the fan base has
just made it a lot harder to like it as
well so are you convinced now or are you
contemplating to say that you're not a
one piece fan anymore because of that
I'm not that I'm not I'm not there yet
cuz I I do still really really [__]
like one piece it's still [__] great
but but you're not going to be as vocal
about it I'm I'm thinking about it I'm
I'm thinking I'm think what happened
with me dog it's uh you know like you
know know there was a good two seasons
of Rick and Morty before uh you couldn't
call yourself a fan of Rick Mor I still
enjoy Rick and Morty even though it's
kind of
ass I have fun with it it's it's it's
fine I I do you think the quality's
actually gotten worse or do you think
it's purely perception I think it has
gone worse
right but it was so good at its peak
that I think that it being worse than
that is still a compliment is its
quality is still good yeah like I'll
take that over whatever the [__] Family
Guy is but I also yeah of course cuz I
feel like I don't know we we don't get a
lot of dark dark humor animated stuff
yeah and you know sometimes the stuff on
Adult Swim is just a little too surreal
or a bit weird for me yeah and I'm like
I don't know so maybe it's a little too
too odd for me um and so it's nice to
have something like that and I feel like
it's polished it's okay it's fine it's
okay to watch